a new home for his family safe from the
violence of the Syrian civil war that's
what drove Hodgins 'his an Muhammad to
seek asylum in Russia for him the
decision was clear I'm not a fighter I'm
a pastry chef I'm a cook that's what I
do I don't want to fight I don't want to
kill people if you want to kill those
poor people that's your choice I don't
want any part of it a son fled Syria
with his wife Illya six years ago just
before the war began they've learned
Russian and are trying to fit in he was
allowed to earn money while his status
was uncertain
now his application for asylum has been
rejected and with it his right to work
he and his family barely get by I want
to work too I tried to get a job in a
kindergarten but they said they couldn't
hire me they said you need documents I
need a medical insurance card but I
don't have any papers or anything when
you the rejections have now made it
impossible for Hassan and his family to
legally work and even go to school here
Russian officials say Hassan can safely
return to Syria but he worries his faith
played a role in the decision honey they
won't give us any documents because
they're scared of Muslims once they
asked me why don't you go to Turkey
they're all Muslim there I said I don't
care there's only one God and he's the
same everywhere
buff's O'Neill Russia's migration
Authority is examining the mass
rejections of Syrian asylum seekers
after a request from DW but the specter
of the war hangs over Syrians here every
day
the Civic Assistance Committee in Moscow
offers legal aid to many of them the
committee's Svetlana ghanoush Tina
doesn't mince words about Russia's
failure to help refugees we don't feel
any responsibility in Russia for what's
happening there are some exceptions like
our organizations but our leaders don't
feel any responsibility Hassan and Aliya
say their responsibility is clear to
find a new safe home for their family
and they hope it will still be here in
Russia